unsupervised analysis methods can help
us understand
structure distance and similarity in our
data
here i have a data set of gene
expression that has
a number of genes six 6918
and a number of samples 52.
these samples can be organized into
different groups
and inside each gene i have its gene
expression values
in fbkm values now if i would like to
understand the relationship between
two genes i can simply make a scatter
plot
and then i will know the relationship
between the expression values of
one vector of a gene and another vector
of another gene
i can do the same for two particular
samples
just looking at two samples i can create
another scatter plot
and see the relationship between them i
would expect
similar genes to have similar expression
and similar samples
that fall under the same group to also
have
a similar expression pattern but when i
come to a data set that has
thousands of genes across tens or
hundreds of samples it's really
difficult to get a grasp or a snapshot
of what that really means unsupervised
analysis of big data can help us
identify patterns relationships and
important structures inside of our data
set
to do that we can go to the unsupervised
analysis section
and upload the data that i was just
showing
since our data is annotated by group i'm
going to press on continue
and select start
pcar library here i have a number of
parameters that i don't really have to
change but what they mean
is the number of output principal
components that i will get in my chart
whether i want to scale or not the data
that i am putting in
do i want to center the data and whether
the data has to be transposed in other
words do i want to look at the
relationship between
samples or objects in my data or genes
in other words
features or rows in my data and so i'm
going to say yes to analyze the
relationship between
samples which are annotated in my data
set
now i will click on end after i click on
end i'm going to give it a second to
create the pipeline
i will name it
save it and now i can run this pipeline
on the cluster
it might take a little bit for the data
set to process depending on the size of
the data set
and the number of users running this
analysis at the same time on the shared
cluster
as soon as the pipeline has completed i
can click on download pipeline output
files
and find some results that include text
files
pdf files and also a packaged
r script that i can use let's take a
look at the plots in pdf
remember their principal component
analysis is a dimensionality reduction
technique
so what we see is that whole data set
reduced to just
two dimensions principle component one
and principal component two
inside these two dimensions we will find
dots that represent
objects or samples in the data set the
distances that we observe
represent a similarity between samples
so when they are closer together
they are more alike and when they are
far apart they are more
different from each other this
difference is based on variance
in the sample data itself so whenever we
see
some two dots closer together that means
that
they are not as varied
compared to the rest of the data set
and that's what you see here in these
percentages
next to pc1 and pc2 this is the total
variance represented by each component
so the variance of pc1 and pc2 together
or the full plot is 12.62
plus 18.08 or about 30 percent
now in the next two pdf plots you will
find
that the same data could be represented
on pc1
and pc3 together representing about
20 25 of the data and
pc3 and pc2 some of these combinations
of principal components show
a much better separation between samples
based on group
based on the annotation that we provided
to the analysis method
so here you can see bazel cloud and low
luminal and normal-like
cloud and low are fairly separate from
all the rest
as well as all of the other colors are
clearly separated
within this principle component space
analyzing the data in such a way can
lead us to generate a novel hypothesis
the hypothesis might be that all the
groups are different
and the biggest difference is between
the luminal
and all of the other samples combined
given this insight we can now test our
hypothesis
developing a supervised analysis method
that would be looking at the differences
between these two groups